elon musk and steve jobs are likely the
two
most innovative people when it comes to
technological revolutions
from the iphone and pixar to
self-driving cars
and self-landing rockets there's no
question that both men
are creative geniuses but at the end of
the day
who comes out on top
[Music]
well starting off let's take a look at
the level of innovation
from each entrepreneur elon musk is
mostly known for his contributions to
the space
and automotive industries more
specifically elon musk has made great
strides in the realms of battery
technology
autonomous driving and autonomous
rockets
of course elon musk has also made
significant contributions
when it comes to reducing the cost of
space flight and the cost of electric
vehicles
but though technological innovation is
very much at play here as well
reducing cost often comes down to
increasing volume to achieve economies
of skill
while also running a super lean and
efficient business
as a result reducing cost is generally a
product
of business innovation as opposed to
technological innovation
though it does play a part with that
being said
the biggest technological advancements
offered to us by elon musk
are likely battery reliability and
vehicle autonomy
meanwhile the first thing that comes to
mind when you think of steve jobs
is no doubt the iphone steve jobs
also had several other revolutionary
products as well
such as the ipod and siri however
one stark difference between the two is
that steve jobs innovations
were generally in the design and ease of
use categories
as opposed to the technological side it
could be argued that innovating on
design
and ease of use is more innovative than
innovating strictly
on technological improvements as
intuitive design
requires much more creativity despite
this
given the raw difficulty of innovating
in the realms that elon musk has
innovated in
i think this category slightly favors
elon musk
but hitting one or two home runs is not
the same
as being a serial innovator both guys
are serial entrepreneurs creating
multiple successful businesses
but this doesn't mean that they are both
serial innovators
if we simply take a look at the
companies that elon musk is currently
working on
they're all innovative however if we
delve into his history
the answer isn't as clear first elon
musk started zip
2 which was basically the yellow pages
of the late 1990s
and then he ventured onto creating
paypal
while these were great ideas they're not
necessarily innovative
in fact when musk's x.com which would
later become paypal
entered the online banking market there
were already
several established players thus elon's
first companies
weren't really revolutionary projects
but simply
business projects this doesn't mean that
growing either of these companies were
easy by any means
however most of the challenges regarding
these companies comes down to business
challenges
as opposed to innovative challenges with
steve jobs on the other hand
his first endeavor itself was apple at
just 21 years old
after starting apple their first product
was the apple 1
which was sold pre-assembled something
that was previously
unseen in the late 1970s and then
they had the apple ii and apple iii and
of course
the very iconic macintosh at this point
steve jobs would get fired from apple
and
during his time away from apple steve
jobs would start next inc
and more notably buy and grow pixar into
a competitive player in the animation
industry
after that when he returned to apple he
bought the imac
and the ipod and the iphone and the ipad
literally everything steve jobs worked
on from a very young age
was innovative if it wasn't innovative
and creative
he simply didn't care meanwhile
elon musk didn't turn his attention to
such projects
until the early 2000s or his mid-30s
with that being said steve jobs
innovative journey
lasted between 1976 and 2011
when he died for a full 35 years
on the other hand at this point in time
elon musk's innovative journey
has only lasted about half that time
period
so currently i believe steve jobs has
the upper hand
when it comes to serial innovation being
an innovator
or a serial innovator is great but
this doesn't really mean much if you
can't sell your idea
or product as a result every innovator
also needs to be a good marketer for
their ideas with elon musk
though he often has a plethora of
ambitious and inspirational ideas
he's not the best when it comes to
communicating them
there are a significant amount of people
who still doubt the various plans
and ideas elon musk has proposed such as
building a mars colony or even
terraforming mars
a lot of the skepticism is of course
because the ideas themselves
would be extremely difficult to
successfully implement
but at the same time i do think elon
musk's presentation skills
aren't exactly helping him in this realm
either in fact
about 10 percent of everything he says
is just
um um
yeah i think you get the point if elon
musk was a more fluid public speaker
it would definitely help him in easing
at least some of the doubt
in his plans meanwhile steve jobs
is one of the best public speaker ceos
in history
after all his marketing skills are
likely the reason that we all use mouses
today despite this public speaking
was not something that he was just
naturally good at
however he knew that effectively
conveying his vision
was extremely important in getting
people on board
and as a result he was sure to
continuously practice
and polish up his presentation skills
which no doubt served him quite well
with that being said there's not really
much competition
in this realm and steve jobs easily
comes out on top
moving on we have likely one of the
largest criteria when judging innovation
which is subsequent impact the iphone
is extraordinarily impactful to the
average person
so far 2.2 billion iphones have been
sold
and even if the average person has gone
through three iphones
this means that one tenth of the entire
world
is currently using iphones and even if
they're using an android smartphone
instead
let's be honest here android wouldn't be
what it is today
without the iphone on top of this the
average person
spends three hours a day on their
smartphones which means that people
literally spend trillions of hours every
single year
on a product that steve jobs made
possible
there is virtually no consumer product
that even comes close
to the daily impact that the iphone has
created
with that being said though elon musk is
more impactful
elon musk will likely never touch each
of our daily lives on a level that steve
jobs
or bill gates were able to but the work
of elon musk
is more beneficial to humanity than a
smartphone or a computer
reducing air pollution promoting clean
energy
and making humans a multi-planetary
species
are extremely important matters and
though we likely could get away without
doing
any of these without too much detriment
to our generation
these are very important for long-term
human sustainability
so despite steve jobs monstrous impact
elon musk is more impactful due to the
nature of his work
and this of course leaves us at a tie
between the two guys
just like any other cliche youtube video
would do
but don't worry there is one more
category that one of them
will win which is their legacy
a trade of any great innovator whether
alexander graham bell
or thomas edison is how they influence
future inventors
and innovators both elon musk and steve
jobs
had and still have a cult-like following
back in the day people would straight up
camp outside of apple stores for
multiple days
before iphone launches to be the first
to get the brand new iphone
since then a slowing in iphone
technological advancements
along with improvements in shipping
which allows people to get the new
iphone
on the day of the launch without all the
hassle have stifled excitement
surrounding iphone launches
despite this iphone launches are one of
the most hyped events
every year with elon musk on the other
hand
his various events are also hyped to the
brim
whether battery day a regular quarterly
report or a simple stock split
everything elon musk does is extremely
hyped
as is evident in the volatility of tesla
stock
in fact tesla is the number one place
engineering students want to work
according to business insider right
alongside tesla spacex comes in at
number two
apple has also ranked very favorably on
such lists for several years at this
point
but they are still lower than elon's
companies at number seven
but the truth is when you get into the
top 10 or even top 100 places to work
for
the satisfaction levels of these workers
are basically identical amongst these
companies
the real difference between the ranks is
how motivated people are
by each of these companies missions and
clearly
tesla and spacex are quite favored
aside from this elon musk has a massive
40 million followers on twitter so the
fan base
of elon musk is quite extensive but
despite all of that i believe steve jobs
has a stronger legacy
for one reason alone which is that elon
musk himself is inspired
by steve jobs elon musk has previously
commented
that no one can replace a void steve
jobs has left behind
and elon musk's admiration for steve
jobs is evident in his approach to
business
and his products as well whether elon's
product oriented focus with the tesla
zero dollar marketing budget
or tesla's minimalist design reminiscent
of steve jobs approach
to product design elon musk has been
significantly inspired
by steve along the way and i think this
sums up
exactly how he feels you know and i know
there was like a
a certain um the guy had a certain magic
about him you know just sort of
that was kind of that was really
inspiring so i mean i think that's
that's really great
is there that magic you trying to
emulate
uh no i i think steve jobs is way cooler
than than i am so
at the end of the day whether you think
steve jobs is more innovative
or elon musk is more innovative
something we can all agree on
is that both of these guys are some of
the most influential people
in history and neither of them can ever
be replaced so let's be thankful that we
were able to witness
two of the greatest people in history
work their magic
during our lifetimes anyways
drop a like if you guys are grateful for
the inventions of both of these guys
also consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and of course consider subscribing to
see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari
and i'll see you guys on the next one